foreign
this morning I've been on the Channel
with our new small boats operational
command
and the whole experience just reinforces
how tragic morally wrong and profoundly
unfair this situation is
we've got organized criminals risking
people's lives
gangs trying to exert the role of
government taking it upon themselves to
decide who comes to our country our
Asylum system is being overwhelmed with
people traveling from safe countries
taking away our capacity to help those
in the greatest need
and the British people are having to
spend six million pounds a day putting
up illegal migrants in hotels
now earlier this year I set out five
priorities to hold inflation grow the
economy reduce debt cut waiting list and
sort the votes today I'd like to update
you on the progress that the Home
Secretary and I are making
and my message is this
our plan is starting to work
before I launched my plan in December
the number entering the UK illegally in
small boats had more than quadrupled in
two years
now some said this problem was insoluble
or just a fact of 21st century life they
lost faith in politicians to put in the
hard yards to do something about it
and of course we still have a long way
to go
but in the five months since I launched
the plan
Crossings are now down 20 compared to
last year
that's right Crossings are down 20
percent
this is the first time since this
problem began
a have fallen compared to the year
before
and this progress is not replicated
across the channel
illegal migrants entering the rest of
Europe have risen by 30 percent
but we are not complacent because we
know people Smugglers are highly
organized and will change their tactics
if we let
I will not rest until the boats are
stopped with grip and determination the
government can fix this and we are using
every tool at our disposal
first I promise to work closely with our
International partners because this is a
global phenomenon there are a hundred
million people displaced around the
world
and European countries alone so almost a
thousand or a million Asylum
applications last year
and this International approach is
delivery our partnership with France
stopped around 33 000.
40 more than the year before
I've put cooperation on tackling illegal
migration on the agenda of every
International Summit I've been to from
the G7 and the Council of Europe to last
week's European political Community
Summit in Moldova last week we agreed a
new action plan with Bulgaria we began
discussions on joint working with the
European border agency contacts
and in December I reached a deal with
Albania
because last year nearly a third of all
those arriving in small boats were from
that safe European country
that's delivering too
we've now returned
1800 to Albania in just six months
we've gone from accepting around one in
five Albanian Asylum cases to now just
one in 50. in line with our European
partners
and what is the result of all of this
well so far this year the number of
albanians small boat arrivals has fallen
by almost 90 percent
this is proof that our deterrent
strategy can work
when people know that if they come here
illegally they won't get to stay they
stop coming
now second I promise to improve in
Folsom so we've doubled the funding
given to the National Crime Agency for
tackling organized immigration crime and
arrests here are the legal workers have
more than doubled
third I promise to stop people
spiritually using modern slavery claims
to frustrate their removal
and since we started asking for basic
evidence to back up modern slavery
claims the refusal rate has tripled
fourth I promise to clear through the
backlog of people waiting for initial
decision numbers published Today Show
that the initial decision Legacy backlog
is down by over 17
000. and we're on track to clear it
entirely by the end of the year
fifth I promise we would get illegal
migrants out of hotels and into
alternative sites including military
facilities
today I can confirm new large sites will
open at Wethersfield and scampton with
hundreds moving in over the summer and
nearly 3 000 by the autumn
and while we're bringing those sites
online we're also making more efficient
use of hotels
by asking people to share rooms where
it's appropriate to do so we found an
additional 11 and a half thousand places
which will save taxpayers an extra 250
million pounds a year
and I say to those migrants who are
objecting this is more than fair
if you're coming here illegally cleaning
Sanctuary from Death torture or
persecution
then you should be willing to share a
taxpayer-funded hotel room in central
London
to reduce pressures on local communities
we'll also House people on ships the
first will arrive in Portland in the
next Fortnight and we've secured another
two today that will accommodate another
thousand
finally I promised not just to reform
our Asylum system but to reform our laws
so we've introduced unprecedented
legislation to make clear that if you
come here illegally you will be detained
and removed in weeks either to your own
country or to a safe Third Country like
Rwanda
our stop the boats bill passed the House
of Commons in weeks despite the labor
party voting against it at every turn
and we're preparing now
so that once any legal challenges are
complete we will be able to put this
bill into practice
I'm ensuring we have more detention
capacity to hold those who arrive
illegally enough Court capacity to
process their cases and the planes to
remove them to Rwanda
I know these are tough measures and I
make no apology for that
we cannot allow our generosity of spirit
to be used as a weapon against us or
against those who are being pushed to
risk their lives in the channel by
criminal gangs our approach is working
for the first time Crossings are down by
20 percent
but we are not complacent this won't be
solved overnight and people will
continue to come this summer which is
why it is so important that we change
the law my policy it's very simple
it is this country and your government
who should decide who comes there and
not criminal gangs I will do what is
necessary to achieve it I said I would
stop the boats
and I meant it
thank you if we uh take some questions
from the media next and could I start
please with the BBC
the problem BBC News you're continuing
to promise to stop the vote so it is on
the left turn in front of you and yet
there has been around seven and a half
thousand migrants who've crossed on
small boats so far this year with summer
months ahead is it credible to promise
to stop them literally no more boats
so thank you Chris I think the most
important people to take away from today
is that our plan is working now I've
always said this isn't an easy problem
to fix we won't fix it overnight and
there's no one simple solution to it but
we're doing a range of things and that's
the plan I announced five months ago but
the message from today is that plan is
working why do I have confidence in that
it's because for the first time since
the small boats phenomenon arose a few
years ago for the first time numbers are
down so this year January to May the
numbers Crossing are down by 20 down by
a fifth well we haven't seen that before
and it is specific to the UK because if
you look at what's happening in Europe
the numbers so far the zero are up
almost a third so I think that to me
shows that the plan we put in place is
working now of course there's work to do
as I said people will still come here in
the summer The Gangs will keep trying
other routes but the measures that we
are putting in place are starting to
work and I think you can see that most
concretely when it comes to the Albanian
situation where the number of crossings
from Albania of illegal migrants from
Albania is down by 90
so I I have confidence that the plan is
working we're obviously not there yet
there's lots of work to do but I'm here
to give people an update on this very
important priority and I think the
message from today is have confidence
because the plan is working numbers are
down for the first ever time and there's
lots more that we're doing
perfect next if we could go to channel
5.
Five News
um do you actually have any evidence
that it is your policies uh of the
Terence that are leading to this drop
and not something like bad weather for
instance that has been actually reducing
the number of people crossing
well thanks Andy I think that there are
two things I point to one is the fact
that Crossings elsewhere in Europe are
up are up by almost a third over a
similar time period And yet Crossings
into the UK are down by a fifth I would
actually tell us something that
something is going on here and that's
the result I think of the actions that
we've put in place and there's a range
of different actions that we've put in
place that are contributing to that and
I think the best example as I'm saying
to Chris earlier is when you look at the
number of illegal migrants coming from
Albania now I think people will remember
when we last spoke about this I said to
everyone the Albania accounted for
around a third of all small boat
arrivals last year a third and Albania
is of course a safe European country so
we put in place a range of changes a new
deal with Albania that that we
negotiated and I pay tribute to generate
immigration Minister the Home Secretary
for all their work on this uh an
Albanian situation and you deal with
Albania that allows us to return people
a change in how we process Albanian
claims and you can see the proof is in
the numbers
so since we've got those changes in
place the rejection or the acceptance
rate for Albanian Asylum claims is now
gone all the way down to around two
percent bringing us in line with our
European
competitors our European neighbors that
wasn't the case before we made all these
changes we were accepting far more
planes from Albania which was not right
so we've made that change and you can
see that we have a new deal with Albania
and now we've returned as I said 1 800
people to Albania since uh we signed the
deal and the number of Albanian
Crossings this year is down by 90
percent
so I think that should give people
confidence that when you do put a system
in place that demonstrates to those who
are interested in thinking about coming
here that they won't get to stay that
they will be returned on the back to
where they came from in the case of
Albania or an alternative arawanda that
you see the numbers come down I think
that's proof that the deterrence effect
can work and we've seen that with
Albania that's why it's important that
we get the Revan the policy up and
running so that we can demonstrate that
terrorist threat to a much broader range
of people as well but I think that as I
said I feel confident that the range of
things we're doing has made a difference
the plan is starting to work and people
feel confident that we can get the job
done
next uh can I turn to the Daily Mail
and the two new
tons the two new bulges where are they
going to be please so on barges we will
wait uh to announce where they're going
to be what I would say is it's really
important to me that we reduce the
number of people in hotels
local communities up and down the
country are seeing the pressure that
it's causing on their areas and there's
obviously the expenses I said six
million pounds a day is being spent on
housing illegal Asylum seekers in hotels
that's not right it's not fair we need
to bring the numbers down we're doing
that in a range of ways large sites
military sites which uh
today also the policy to have sometimes
leave this share rooms to increase
capacity and save the taxpayer money
which I think is entirely reasonable and
fair but also vessels and barges well
how much how much notice will people be
given
in communities say Portland for example
and there's been quite a lot of concern
about the Stockholm
enough notice um so that they can
be prepared for perhaps what is coming
yeah so thank you yeah so we we do
extensive engagement with local
communities in advance of
five sides or barges of course we should
do that that's the right thing to do
that's what we do do there are
multi-agency forums that are established
at a local level to bring together all
the local stakeholders where appropriate
there's 24 7 police and security
protection and of course local areas get
funding to make sure that they have the
resources and support they need to
provide any services that are required
so that's the work that goes on but what
I am pleased is that we have now not
just one barge arriving in a fortnight
in Portland that we've secured two
further votes today and then we will
work with the detail and implementation
of those but I think all of that again
just demonstrates the government putting
in the hard yards doing things that
people say quite frankly were not
possible they said this wouldn't be
workable it wasn't possible we have
persevered
put the elbow grease in and now we have
one coming two more on their way that's
you know that will hopefully over time
mean thousands of Extra Spaces which
will relieve pressure on local
communities because people would like
that hotels to be returned to their
normal use this is a way to do it and
we're making good progress on that next
can I turn to the Sun
you say that your plan's working but you
won't say that you will stop votes by
Christmas what number does success look
like to you and secondly it's also been
reported you will raise Ben Wallace's
candidacy for NATO General Secretary
with Joe Biden this week uh is it time
for a brick to lead NATO
so Natasha on on numbers I'll let other
people other people will judge how well
we're doing and the purpose of today's
update is to give people a sense of
progress and I believe there's reasons
to be confident that our plan is working
we've been through the numbers but it's
not just the number of people coming
that is coming down we're making
progress on hotels we're making progress
on getting the backlog down we're also
making progress on in enforcement and
what you've seen is the number of of
Eagle working raids has gone up by 50
that was one of the things that I talked
about we've also doubled the number of
arrests from uh
our activity tackling illegal working
and again that's all part of the plan it
all creates a deterrence effect that
people should not try and come here
illegally so we've made progress there
as well so across all the aspects of the
10 points that I spoke about when I
launched the plan uh at the end of last
year I think people can see that we're
making progress in all of them but
crucially the numbers are down and
there's yeah lots more to come and then
people obviously can can make a judge
whether we're doing a good enough job or
not I believe we've made more progress
on this issue than anyone's made in a
very long time because it's first time
to come down and then on NATO I think
that Ben does a fantastic job he's a
great defense secretary this is a
conversation that is happening amongst
leaders around the world more generally
and I'm sure it will continue to happen
I would say Ben is widely respected
amongst his colleagues around the world
particularly for the role he's played in
Ukraine and supporting Ukraine and and
Britain has always been a leading
contributor to Nato where one of the
handful of countries that always met Our
obligation to spend two percent of our
GDP on defense currently we're spending
even more than that and we've been a
leader in NATO operations we're one of
the only countries that participates in
every single NATO operation we're widely
perceived as a thought leader in NATO
and I think if you alternator Secretary
General he would he would agree with
everything I've just said and we would
always continue to be a strong
contributor a participant in NATO
uh next uh can I know kind of conscious
of time as well can I say the Kent
online
um
the uh illegal migration bill is going
through the laws today are you worried
that that might stall things because the
Lords have had a opposition towards uh
anti the illegal England policy in the
past
thanks uh thanks Sam so it's really
important for me to see this new law on
the statute books you know it's one of
my five priorities I believe it's the
country's priority as well to see the
boat stopped and this new law is an
important part of how we will do that
why because this law makes it
unequivocally clear that if you come to
our country illegally you will not be
able to stay instead you will be swiftly
detained and then sent back either to
your own country if it's safe to do so
or to Rwanda or another Third Country
alternative that's the process that this
bill puts in place and it means that
people will be processed in a matter of
days and weeks not months and years and
if we can get that working the deterrent
effect I think will be very powerful
that's why the better so important I'm
pleased to say it was passed in the
House of Commons in a matter of weeks
with strong support although the labor
party did oppose it at each and every
term but it is important to me that this
bill does us they get put on this
actually works because it's important
part of how we will stop the boats but
I'd also say that I'm already doing the
work now to make sure that when the bill
does come into law and manages any legal
challenges that that we may have to deal
with that will be all ready to implement
it so I'm already doing meetings almost
twice a week with all the relevant uh
secretaries to make sure that all the
all the building blocks and elements of
operationalizing the bill will be put in
place in advance so that's making sure
we have enough detention capacity to
detain people it's making sure we have
enough judicial capacity to hear
people's cases and claims in a matter of
days and weeks and it's making sure that
we have all the logistics in place to
actually remove people to Rwanda you
know all of that is hard work and we're
at it now as I said twice a week making
sure that we've got everything ready so
that when the bill comes into law and is
ready to be used that we are absolutely
ready to use it as soon as possible
um and then we've got time maybe for a
couple more perfect right uh can I go to
um ITV Meridian I've got local ITV
there have been very few uh almost all
small boat across things that have
arrived in the UK arrived here in Kent
and that's been a huge pressure on
public services can I ask what you're
doing to address that and can I also say
it's been exceptionally windy in the
channel for several days now meaning
they've been hardly any small breakfast
things is that why you've chosen to come
here today
so uh Abby thanks on um
yeah first of all I'll just pay tribute
to Natalie who's who's here as a local
MP and actually spends an enormous
amount of time when she's in Westminster
talking to me and other ministers to
make sure that Dover and Kenmore
generally is getting the support and
engagement that it needs to deal with
the challenges that small boat
causes you know because athletes
campaigning we've invested quite a lot
and I think the first leveling up funds
came because everyone was 40 million
pounds so infrastructure improvements uh
to make sure that migration processing
was much easier as well as working very
closely with Council and other
authorities here and to deal with
everything and more generally just
investing in the local community whether
it's through our house group funds our
towns funding our leveling up funding I
think Kent and the local communities
here are seeing that investment go into
their local areas as well distinct from
the specific resources that we're
putting in place to deal with this I
think the thing the best way to relieve
that pressure is to stop people from
coming in the first place right so
rather than creating the symptoms as you
treat the cause that's why the bill is
so important it's why we need to pass
new laws have international agreements
get the backlog done if we do all of
those things we can move to a system
which means people won't won't be able
to stay if they come here illegally into
this part of the country or anywhere
else I think we will see people stop
coming right and that's the best way to
relieve the pressure on the community
here and I want them to be reassured
that it is one of my five priorities as
they can see it's very important to me
and the message to take away from today
is the plan is working so for the first
time since this small boat is phenomenon
Came Upon Us the numbers are down down
by almost a fifth this year
and I think as we've gone through all
the reasons why I think that is a sign
of encouragement but we are not
complacent of course the summer is uh
coming of course gangs will keep trying
different routes and different
methodologies we need to be alert to
that it's why we need to pass the law
it's so important that the law passes
because that will really help us resolve
this problem and in terms of the time we
don't want to visit there's many things
I can't control the weather is not one
of them so I wish it was so
um right uh but actually I think there's
a second at least the second and the
third time I've I've been here it's
actually very good to see the team here
locally who are doing such incredible
work firstly to say thank you to them
because I said that the progress we've
made since we've got the planet place is
more than they deserve enormous credit
for it but the second thing is as I said
at the opening of my remarks when you
talk to the teens here who are the ones
who are out on the front line
picking moments off I think it really
brings home how awful and tragic this
situation is right you talk to them and
they will talk to you just the other
week picking up toddlers
who were suffering from hypothermia
in a makeshift dinghy that was not
remotely seaworldly right I mean with
some of us around the boat earlier
before trying our hardest you know to
get ill to deal with the weather if
you're in a makeshift dinghy which is
it's not seaworthy where it is freezing
in conditions that are far worse than
today and children are being exposed to
that I'm sorry but that is completely
and utterly wrong
and when you talk to the team here are
the ones who have to deal with that on a
daily basis and rescue those people you
know they will tell you that it's wrong
and that's why the moral thing to do the
compassionate thing to do is to stop
these criminal gangs from being able to
exploit people like that and put them on
these rafts and send them across the
chapel and it is wrong and that's why
it's right but we're doing everything we
can to stop it I think absolutely last
last one we've got the times
you spent half a billion pounds to
French in March I think it was are you
satisfied the French doing enough to
stop the boats what is their
interception rates and what interception
rate would be would be regarding for
money if there is taxpayer and secondly
just you were talking about how trudging
it was to seeing children
across those uh conditions you're
planning to detain children indefinitely
are you going to put a time limit on
that when the bill comes to the Lords or
the comments later this summer
so thanks man on on
on detention the reason that's in place
is that you don't want to create an
incentive for people for people to put
children on these phones right so if you
Exempted children from the policy then
it would you'd give every incentive for
people to bring children along with them
and you put more Children at Risk
actually so I don't think that's the
right thing to do and that's why they
are included now obviously there are
appropriate facilities for families
they're not separated they're kept
together and we need to make sure that
that's done properly and fairly as it
always has been and will continue to be
so but I think it would be a mistake to
exclude children because I said it would
just create an incentive for people to
put more children on the boats and that
would be awful and now we've gone to the
French uh deal uh yes I think the
Friendship is already showing progress
we you know last year we we stopped
around 33 on the French stopped around
33 000 people from Crossing that was uh
I think 40 more than the year before so
that gives you a sense that the numbers
are improving the deception rate whether
you measure it on the first quarter or
the first five months of the year is up
considerably on last year
um and there's more to come now what the
deal does is it it represents a massive
uplift on the number of law enforcement
officers who are being deployed by the
French in northern France about a 500
person uplift half of which will be in
place this year it also means that we
will create they will create a zonal
coordination Center uh probably in in
Neil de la in northern France and that
will bring together for the first time
all the different aspects of their
response to this in one place which will
really help also we will have British
officers as part of our setup for the
first time to approve the coordination
between us that's something that we
think can make a big difference and then
the last element of it is the
intelligence corporation uh set sharing
of surveillance and reconnaissance
technology
and then the kind of slightly longer
term thing which we've agreed to as a
new migrant Detention Center in Dunkirk
but that will take a little bit of time
to come on stream right so those are all
the elements of what the deal with
France represents as you can see in the
numbers this year versus last year last
year that's the year before there is a
steady upward uh
increase in the interception rate of the
number of people who are being stopped
and I think that will continue to happen
as our cooperation continues to deepen
and that the deal that we announced is
fully implemented and operationalized
but it's a good point to end on because
it reminds us that this is not a UK only
phenomenon and I'm in the Summits when
I'm talking to other leaders there's
plenty of other countries that are
grappling with the same thing I talk
about the numbers in Europe we all
remember the tragedy that happened off
the coast of Italy last year which is
why I'm finding more and more countries
are Keen to work with us to tackle this
problem one of the things to others
actually did very early on after became
prime minister her and I re-established
the Calais group of northern European
nations to come together to work
together to tackle this problem and then
we've built on that with our deals with
France deals with Albania cooperation
with Italy and now many more countries
and you will continue to see that
because ultimately we are not alone in
facing this challenge but what today's
numbers show is that we the UK are
making progress on gripping it and
that's the the main message for people
to take away from today is our plan is
working we're not complacent there's
more work to do but people should have
confidence that when I said I was going
to stop the boats I meant it and that's
what we're delivering thank you very
much
[Music]